the national institutes of health and
u.s drug maker eli lilly are launching
two clinical trials to test a new
approach to treating the coronavirus
it uses antibodies that are
mass-produced in a lab to try to stop
the virus from damaging the body
coronavirus patients at certain u.s
hospitals can volunteer
now to enroll in these trials cbs news
chief medical correspondent dr john
lepouk explains
why this is so significant it's
basically
taking what our own bodies are capable
of doing
to protect us and trying to offer that
to somebody
who had has not yet mounted their own
effective defense
nih director dr francis collins is
overseeing a treatment he hopes will
block the coronavirus in infected
patients
using monoclonal antibodies that
monoclonal antibody sticks
right to the part of this spike protein
that represents the part that binds to
the human cell and lets the virus get
inside
so you cover that up and the virus has
nowhere to go
so unlike plasma donated by survivors
which contains antibodies to coronavirus
and
other past infections monoclonal
antibodies target
only the part of the virus that allows
it to attack human cells
and importantly they can be mass
produced in a lab
if it turns out the clinical trial is
successful we can start immediately
offering this to patients who are sick
us biotech company regeneron is also
developing its own
lab produced antibody treatment dr
mezgeba
is running the trial if i treat you now
can i prevent
the possibility of progression and
hospital admission
can i uh improve your recovery time
can i also prevent transmission to other
people marion gaffney and her husband
michael senec are participating in a
regeneron trial
to see if monoclonal antibodies can
prevent covet 19
in someone exposed to the virus if we
got the antibody and it did some good
at least we were in a position to take
advantage of it
all right john so john i think one of
the questions people are asking you now
is
would this be safer or less safe than
the
plasma treat treatment that comes from
survivors when it comes to antibodies
well it should be safe uh theoretically
remember the convalescent plasma taken
from survivors
has all sorts of antibodies including
antibodies to parts of the corona virus
that really don't hurt it very much
these are kind of designer monoclonal
antibodies that only attack the part of
the coronavirus
that allows the coronavirus to attack
human cells
so theoretically it should be safe and
it should be more effective
we'll see these trials that are going to
see of whether it's able to prevent
infection
in somebody who's already been exposed
and for people who have mild
or serious disease well that remains to
be seen and john have that
does the lab antibody treatment have any
impact on vaccine development are you
still optimistic that a vaccine comes
late this year early next
yeah i think we're we supposedly are on
target for a vaccine
but not for several months this
hopefully can be a bridge to that
remember this is not actually a vaccine
it's giving you temporary immunity
hopefully
an immune factor that helps you fight
this infection but after a month or
maybe two
that antibody the monoclonal antibody
should be out of your system uh for all
intents and purposes
it is not going to help you in the long
run to say prevent infection
down the road in you know in 6 12 months
all right some great information dr john
the poop thank you very much